how to get more followers on twitter I
got a question from one of my readers
and Marie Cox are willing to say how do
I get more followers on twitter I'm
passionate about this and I have a
different approach than most people okay
I'm not going to tell you to follow
certain hashtags and talk about trending
topics or to auto follow people hoping
that they'll follow you back or to Spain
people i don't use any of the automated
tricks maybe that stuff works I don't
know but it's not my approach so so how
do i do it here is the Evan Carmichael
approach to getting followers on twitter
okay the first part is back up from this
okay forget about Twitter for now think
about what is your company stand for
what mission are you on what big problem
exists in the world that you're trying
to solve in my view until you figure
that out you don't really have a
business you don't really have anything
we're talking about on twitter you have
to stand for something important so what
is that what's the change you want to
make in the world identify that then
step two is start posting things that
are relevant to that topic pictures
quotes sayings stories articles things
that you find inspiring that help you
because it can help other people as well
as part of your movement and then three
start interacting with people on Twitter
who either could use your help could use
your expertise or are also on the same
mission as you and are doing something
important and you want to recognize them
those are my three steps and let me tell
you how I use it myself okay for me it's
all about entrepreneurship I love
entrepreneurs I want to help a billion
entrepreneurs I want people to believe
in themselves people if you have an idea
to make a business and you're too afraid
to get started or or the little man in
your life is holding you back and
telling you you can't do it I want you
to do it I want you to believe in
yourself passionate about this hopefully
that comes through in all these videos
and everything I'm doing so that's what
I stand for step two is I share quotes I
share pictures I share articles i share
saenz i share stories that that inspire
me I look at something that is
fires me and then I share that you want
to be proud of each tweet that you send
out it's not instead about how many you
send out but you want to be proud of
what you're saying right you look at die
and say yeah that tweet that means
something those are the kind of tweets
are like sending out so sharing things
that are important to me an important
part of this entrepreneurship movement
that's what I like putting it and then
three start interacting with people and
the two types of people I interact with
our other entrepreneurs so aren't
furnace who need help my trees I have a
question just just like you on trees
will have a question who I can help them
and I'll either write to them on Twitter
right back on Twitter or make a youtube
video other social media whatever it
takes but I enjoy helping entrepreneurs
so I reach out to them and the second
part are people who are on the same
mission as mean doing something that I
think is important so here a couple
examples Marcus lemonis he has a show
called The Prophet it's on CNBC it's a
pretty new show just about to get into
its second season and I love the show
and it's important because he's out
there helping entrepreneurs and he's
helping teach entrepreneurs how to be
successful and he invests in the
business and in my view not enough
people know about this show I have no
connection the markets other than the
show I have no I'm not being paid to
talk about the show I just think it's
important not enough people know about
it you should watch the show and so I
reached out to Marcus and I tweet some
of his stuff and I share some of his
stuff and now he follows me that's how a
lot of the stuff works I reach out to
people on the Sharks tank I love the
show shark tank we have one in Canada
called Dragon's Den too and I reach out
to those people and just thank them and
recognize them and tell them what you're
doing is important you think about it
think about TV before sharks tank and
before the profit there was nothing for
entrepreneurs right shark tank has made
entrepreneurship sexy again and also
helps instill some business knowledge
that helps train people you look at the
entrepreneurs who are coming on now
they're much more well-versed they
understand things better than in the
first season people watch the show they
watch it with their kids and they're
getting an education so I think this
is an important show there's a lot of
entertainment with the two I get that
but it's still education on its helping
entrepreneurs so I'll tweet that I'll
tweet the Sharks I'll tweet the dragons
and tell them what they do is important
i'll share some of the stuff that
they're quoting and in return do you get
to know about me and they see what i
right and if they like it they may share
some of that with their audience so
that's how it works so to summarize
again you start off one with with a big
goal a big vision the problem with the
world that you want to change create
your movement that's step one number to
start sharing things that are important
to you important part of this movement
things that you believe in every tweet
you should love that you put out it
excites you motivates you moves you and
number three start interacting with
people who could either use your help
who are also part of this movement who
are doing great things and you want to
recognize them that's my plan to build a
Twitter following I've got about two
hundred thousand people on Twitter now
who follow me and it's growing every day
and that's the recipe i use so hopefully
you can apply it to your business see
similar results i hope you do it good
luck and believe for those of you
watching like the video give it a thumbs
up below leave a comment let me know
what you think ask the question below
make a video response subscribe to the
channel if you want to see more videos
like this thank you so much and I'll see
you soon